Taoism
philosophical study of flow lao-tzu
the daodejing
been studying this a lot more recently
that which offers no resistance
overcomes the hardest substances that
which offers no resistance can enter
where there is no space let's start with
wool way wool way means a non-action
effortless action or action of non
action wool way is the state of flow
being in the zone having action without
striving move through space and time
without action flow in its natural
course the Tao the Ching is actually the
most translated work after the Bible the
Dao means the way and we have a lot of
limitations in our perception of
understanding what is this the way the
Dow that can be described is not the
eternal Dow in many ways it feels as
though the Dow is from the moment of
creation until now and where it's going
and are we on the Dow or have we
beard-off the Dow it's a very
interesting question is maybe the Dow
exactly where we are now or was the Dow
or is it potentially this more pinnacle
civilizational evolution where we have
more actualization both as ourselves in
our collective where there's less
malevolence --is
another big part of Taoism is the
curbing of the senses this ascetic
mentality asceticism where you give up
the urge for the sensual pleasures so
jumping around all the time can I get
some food can I can I have some sex can
I go and have something that's this
transient immediate gratification
experience versus the I'm just gonna
recognize that that instant
gratification pleasure came up and I'm
just not gonna react to it I'm just
gonna be with it I'm not gonna go and go
after my impulse right away and that's
why in a world where we're so overfed
and we're so overstimulated these
ancient practices of meditation of
fasting and a focus I actually have the
greatest potential at helping us
identify what our most creative
potential is on this planet can we have
the stillness of mind that is so
discussed in the DAO can we have the
humility the cessation of striving so
it's that we both know that we will be
expressing this beautiful gift of ours
into the world this North Star but that
we can effortlessly flow like water
towards that North Star and this is
difficult there are so many times when
we want to do some sort of an action I
have to do this right now what if we
flowed like water through that action
and that we were in a constant state of
flow with our journeys
it's the idea that perception and
understanding come to a stop and instead
spirit moves us this is delicate balance
between Chronos and Kairos to wear with
Chronos is all about the time and with
Kairos is about this flow like the river
and so we know that if we make the plan
with someone that we want to be on time
for that and we keep that in mind as we
flow the power of gentleness this is
like swimming you don't want to over
exert energy as you assume you want to
swim like you're in flow with the water
approaching tasks intelligently finding
the balances between action and
non-action the golden path between
anxiety and boredom that's just at the
perfect skill level for you to
constantly be in flow we look down on
passivity but doing nothing sometimes
makes more sense and this has actually
been really critical most recently with
this idea that does my consciousness
actually transform the most in a social
setting or even when I'm alone when I'm
constantly feeding myself with stimuli
when I'm alone or when I'm with people
that were constantly talking to each
other or is it potential that my
consciousness transforms more if I turn
off all of the stimulation when I'm
alone and I just sit and I'd be maybe I
have more profound realizations actually
come up that both help me develop as a
person and help my unique gifts come up
through the world and when we're with
other people instead of all talking
maybe we pause everyone and we say hey
guys can we just be together for a
little bit and as you just be and no one
talks but some people maybe have their
eyes closed some of their eyes open kind
of looking at each other the feeling the
energy feeling the dynamics between each
other more beautiful things can arise in
evolution of your consciousness than if
you were all talking life is like a
river that already has a course we can
swim upstream we can swim downstream we
can try and hold the branch we can stand
on a rock along the way you just follow
the flow of the river the mind thinks it
should control the environment to
survive but we don't control our
digestion we don't control our blood
flow we don't control the healing of our
wounds the future who we fall in love
with who we find attractive how nature
unfolds so we navigate through the river
instead of trying to control it again
navigate through the river instead of
trying to control it animals plants and
insects are all rolling with the flow
you can see and feel the spirit inside
of animals and insects and plants that
they're all just in a state of spirit of
existing of just being part of this flow
of this unfolding and then the human
creature is the one that goes oh my god
the future oh my god and oh my god the
past oh my god we create all of that but
really this beautiful state of just
being being on the Dow navigating the
river of our own journey of bringing
gifts of the world in life
with qualities of water our softness the
supreme good is like water which
benefits all of creation without trying
to compete with it so water bring so
much good it brings humans plants
animals insects it brings life
nourishment that we need to survive but
doesn't compete with it it just flows
water has no purpose no goal no specific
desires but it nourishes water does
God's work without any ambition can you
can I can we all do God's work without
ambition maybe the balance of both
knowing again that we have this ultimate
gift that we want to bring but we're
gonna let ourselves flow divinely to
that gift when you're in flow you forget
about the results you forget about
anxiety you forget about the past you
let it go and you stay in flow a plant
like this beautiful tree that I planted
with my mother 11 years ago it may seek
out the sunlight but it does not chase
after the sunlight so we seek out our
North Star and the gifts we don't chase
after it we flow towards it sometimes
the best way to fight is to not fight at
all win by appearing to do nothing
we've all been there some sort of a
stressful situation that's boiling and
what do we do we don't react we stay
calm we observe and all of a sudden the
situation diffuses itself we approach
those situations with peace with
equanimity with love and care and
compassion water can flow or it can
crash choose wisely and be like water my
friend
also remember that nature is the best
teacher as I sit here I feel Earth I
feel the trees I feel the air I have
insects on me this is life these are the
lessons that we can learn by observing
and experiencing creation God's source
we learn so much by just being with
nature that is a massive part of the DAO
is the evolution of all that is and
being with that flow of watching and
feeling and integrating with how nature
evolves and being a part of that also a
more body being in love with fate
and so there's some sort of a balance to
strike between having this gift that
we're bringing forth into the world
being in love with fate with whatever it
is however it is that we bring this gift
forth into the world but also knowing
that we want to bring forth our unique
gift so how do you balance something
like sitting back with going forth it's
a very beautiful thing how in love with
you are you with your history love a
fate of your history of every time slice
that you've lived from birth until now
because the more you are in love with
the fate the more you've integrated it
into your essence and your being more
holistically you'll live there more
holistically your present moment will be
in your future will be have that amor
fati that love of faith - the dow is a
very interesting concept is the way it
is the flow of the universe the flow of
creation the flow of source that we're
all experiencing together moment to
moment
and one of the ultimate questions of
existence
how do you flow with the Dow most
optimally are we exactly where we're
supposed to be right on the Dow is there
something that we've lost from knowing
how to behave more like a pinnacle
civilization more in harmony with
creation with nature with the source
that we need to recover and embed again
so beautiful questions study more about
Taoism study more of the daodejing
study more about Lao Tzu the philosophy
of flow Wu Wei non-action effortless
action the action of non action study
these things and really tap more deeply
into bringing your gifts into the world
but doing it with the flow doing it
effortlessly
it's a gorgeous thing have more
conversation with your friends your
family's co-workers people online about
the Dow about Taoism about bringing your
gifts effortlessly into the world
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders around the world
that you believe and support them and
help them grow support us our links are
below simulation find the rest of our
great interviews and videos with leaders
from around the world trying to inspire
you to build the future I host it my
name is Alan Saki on and also
bring your gifts forward and then NFS
your dreams into the world everyone be
with the flow view with the doubt I love
it very much thank you for tuning in
I'll see you soon peace